have you seen those videos the videos is
what's crazy cuz you have like eight
dudes right and everyone's 45° CH the
they got the stand as soon as they go as
[Music]
soon and welcome back to another episode
of careful boys today we have Barton
Nick over here Anthony and Joe and we
have H's back with he's back he's back
the legend the do that's right man zad's
back with the Z welcome back we missed
you bro thanks you got the cholo glasses
I like it hey gracias oh these are the
true cholo ones oh those are logs dude
you look like my uh middle school
bully that's what Japanese guy yeah it
looks like that that Asian guy that's
American me you know what I mean Open
Your Eyes Open Your Eyes Open Your Eyes
did uh what do you think about those uh
those guys in Japan that like picked up
the Cho culture and they look like just
mexic that's crazy huh yeah the low
riders and everything the low riders
yeah dude that's wild yeah they I think
their God is Mr caponi they're pretty
legit I don't know who's Mr caponi
that's their God that's their God that's
their Jesus damn cuz they'll even have
the Mexican flags on the low riders
that's crazy I know
right yeah I can't picture them like
listening to Little Rob as the sun's
going down they're just like Oly you
know what I mean I think they waited
until uh pocos went on and then you know
a lot about the are you one of them low
key you're just like played it off from
La bro I think he's he's the LA guy yeah
yeah yeah like what do you feel when you
see this stuff well what do I feel
erection when I see them girls like is
that actually like attractive in a way
uh a Japanese like Chola Chola Japanese
huh I think hold on that's a new fantasy
right there you got some action uh I
feel some throbbing yeah
a CH dude that right yes I'm [__]
that you know what I mean like that
right here oh my kind she can protect
you what about the low rider fight with
you what about the low rider models type
in J uh low rider Japan and then the
cover the cover they'll be Chola girls
and bikinis the videos have you seen
those videos the videos is what's crazy
cuz you have like eight dudes right and
everyone's [__] 45 degree [__]
like CH the [__] out they got the stand
and as soon as they go
after they automatically become but the
photos the photos look hard as [__] but
right after like go back to
Japanese just doing the robot that's
sick yeah I'm like they looks so [__]
hard for that photo I didn't realize
that that's like my new thing now dude
you [__] in Vietnam there's this
barber shop called Liam Barber and their
whole theme and aesthetic is cholo oh
[__] yeah dead end time times but she's
Mexican no bro there her name's K koruu
koru or she look Mexican k k I like it
maybe she's half you think there's a
bunch of half out there huh you know
there was this period during like uh
during like the pandemic when everything
was racially all [__] super super hot
um where people started getting mad at
like the Japanese culture for
appropriating like Latino culture and
stuff or like some young people that
have no idea how long the history's been
there and then there like OG's in like
the the like popping community that like
went over there back in like the '90s
and stuff and we like selling them
[__] you know like the the flannel
selling them LS teaching them the
culture and was like yo we sold them the
culture you can't get mad at them when
they like bought up what we gave them
also dude it's like I'm okay white
people stop complaining for us Latinos
one thing that we love is when people
try to do our culture
we away with theam
glasses
we want that dude if a Asian guy speaks
Spanish we're like you know Spanish get
out we love that [__] yeah my [__] my
dad was all hyped though one of my
friends was Asian and he just like loved
him the most cuz he wasn't afraid to eat
manulo everybody else is like I don't
know what that is and then he just like
yeah cuz you know F y'all be eating some
wild [__] so that was nothing that was
just like walk in the park for him he's
like [__] I love manood and my dad's
like B I thought you guys guy has
Mexican
power that's like similar to when they
ask like uh Chinatown Merchants like old
Asians like if they like when people
wear like the rice hat of course it pay
by Bill by that's one of the saddest
[__] like all these chinatowns are dying
because white people are afraid to buy
the [__] clothes and hats and jewelry
and everything they don't buy prom
dresses there no more like that dude
when they were PR that [__] was kind of
funny you know those like Chinese or
like Vietnamese looking prom dress
Mandarin collar with the yes he's into
it or those Chinese but you guys don't
buy that no no we want to sell them but
white people get mad that their white
sisters are buying it yeah but we want
to sell them and then all these chinat
towns are now dying because no one goes
to those shops and buys the [__] no I
blame some of the Asian-American
girl Asian Amer for sure I blame the
Asian-American girls Boba girls right
the [__] Boba liberals man yeah it's
a it's a it's a it's a tough look you
know what I mean as far as like it's
hard to pull off it it's just it's very
like it's Asian yeah you know what I'm
saying it's not like a robe where you
can play it off like oh it's like
Versace it is what what about the hat
with a little braid huh you seen the hat
with a little braid you know what I mean
who's going to pull that off the iron
monkey hat yeah the iron monkey hat the
policeman from Iron Monkey I used to
have one of those when I was a little
kid and I would wrap around my neck and
[__] like like Wong Fong you know what I
mean like we used to have one of those
you know growing up that's really how I
felt though growing up it's like you
just see the world right and then to me
even black and white is closer than a
the minute Like You on screen if you
have like a Armenian Mexican whatever
everyone kind of looks like it's like
fitting into a world and then the first
Asian guy that shows up it's
like basically these hat oh [__] no
either one either one you don't like it
bro you don't like the the long it makes
me uncomfortable seeing it cuz I feel
like is it racist cuz this is like so
like are these guys being racist let me
tell you why let me tell these guys are
racist those are Mexicans wearing that
whenever they like Disney or anybody try
to like mimic an Asian there's the go to
so and then now that they're talking
about it how it's offensive so I'm like
but that's the thing Asian [__] is so
Asian it already looks
racist it does look like a costume it's
so Asian it's racist even the Asian dude
from uh blood and blood out he looks
racist yes like if a white guy dreamed
up what's a racist Asian is that guy
right there you got a good point yeah
you're just like guy you're you're too
Asian right now dude you're too Asian
you're turning racist yeah yeah it's so
funny dude cuz I know what you're
talking about Asians like in Asia are
pretty like racist yeah yeah hell yeah
and and it's not the same as like racism
in in America is a different it's like a
lot of like you'll kill for it but over
there they're just like judgmental
racism yeah but they're also just
judgmental in general you know if I wore
this right so they're just judgmental
descriptive and race is one of the
descriptions if I wore that and I walked
in
here don't tell me you wouldn't be like
yo what the
[__] walking in here walking in here
wait wait right here is different baby
I'll be just I'll be right in with y'all
it's different here man yeah okay if I
go to like a next door next door
something next yeah one of these little
the turtle chips Guy They'll just be
like you and I'm just be like player
like I'm trying to blend in with you
guys give us give us your best Asian
accent go ahead
oh I walk in and I'm just
like I'm not sure what they're saying
but I just hear
sounds and that's pretty good and that's
the the go bring him my knife or Sword
whatever go bring
he's sushi that was a sushi chef right
now yeah that's a sushi chef he's a
tough old man but if you walked into a
place that was old Asians I think they
would have a good laugh laugh you think
so yeah yeah yeah but if you went into
like they'll probably take pictures with
you but if you were walking around like
uine campus with like college Asians
they would just young as they would have
rage tears rage tears yeah rage tear the
difference between American racism and
Asian racism is America Asian racism
they're [__] racist but it doesn't
matter no no so American racism got
American racism actually doesn't um
isn't really racist but it matters a lot
yeah you know what I mean like American
racism is you'll get someone being
violent toward you cuz they hate you
Asian racism is they're just making fun
of you yeah like like they can go hard
but at the end of the day it doesn't
even [__] matter
like asan racism isn't like I I don't I
don't serve your kind around here yes
they go as far as like they'll
physically try to do something because
of your uh ethnicity right Mexicans are
the saying way we make fun but that's as
far as we go it's it's a big goof we're
just goofing right but it won't go as
far as that like yeah I think the oh I I
think I got it the difference is when a
Westerner has racism they think you're
evil they think you're like a bad
subhuman you're an animal
whatever but then when when Asians are
racist they're just stupid like they're
like they just have dumbass ideas but
they also just give me an example
something that that would be dumb a dumb
idea a dumb racist idea or they just so
for example right I I would say it's
like dumb they're just roasting right
they're just or they're being silly
right they're just being silly like
you'll see like funny videos in villages
of like China or something like that
where like a black dude's walking around
and all the kids want to take photos
with them because they don't see them
that often and that's just unique so
they're just like w that skin color is
really really different we got to take
photos but consider touching you and
[__] they'll touch your hair you know if
you're black dude they might touch I but
when I worked with I got you you know
what I mean yeah when I worked at the uh
the Korean restaurant I remember one of
the cooks is like tortilla but it was
rice paper and then he just
like he's like yeah you but it was like
it was see through and I was like what
the [__] and
then and lunch break we we'll eat some
of the food there and we had the meat
and the and the rice and stuff and then
I remember I was trying to look for
tortilla he rolled it like a burrito it
was like C like God damn it was probably
really good man damn Asian restaurant
they'll they could be racist as [__] but
they'll still serve you yeah no matter
what correct but then an American one if
they're racist they like you don't align
with my
values
so it's like it it matters a lot but
they're not even that I'm not going to
bake you a gay cake yeah exactly yeah
yeah yeah yeah a groom and a groom not
on my cake can't eat my
sandwiches it's like an Asian they'll be
like all right I'll make your gay ass
cake yeah it's gay but I'll do it and
I'll just call you gay in front of your
face hey these two gay guy getting
married make a
thousand it'll probably make fun of you
the whole time and then they'll start
making fun of their niece or something
that's also gay that they excluded from
the family my niece is gay my niece is
gay just like you you guys are so gay
maybe you guys should get
married maybe that's also because in
Asia they just don't turn down the
almighty like yeah the dollar the
skrilla if you will yeah they're not
going to that's like number one right
that's foolish yeah businessman that's
smart I don't think I think I think they
they uh just point out differences a lot
and then he just rast cuz like oh you're
[__] fat look at you [__] big eyes
look at you big nose they'll just clown
you but that I think ltin do that too
like they just have a nickname for you
they just make fun of you so my dad we
I'm making this into a bit but like the
fast version is like we ran into like a
transgender person and I was like
nervous cuz my dad's staring too hard
and I'm just stare he's
like
beard this just keep it moving but he's
keep it moving don't look look cing out
it hey wait and I'm like just don't
ignore it ignore it and he's like ignore
it I can talk to whoever that's what's
wrong with
Society no one's talking no it's
normal walk told just like hey good
morning
sir already off to a bad start huh yeah
I identify as they them well I like they
I don't like
them I like they not them oh it's okay I
like they I don't like them but you know
and he tries to relate to them as like
saying like no I have um we have people
like you in Mexico CH we have that in
Mexico that sounds like a good sandwich
sh and I'm just she yeah so I couldn't
you know I just had to pull him get the
[__] let's go I had to apologize for him
but yeah so but they mean well they're
trying to learn I think that's the thing
is in like people are [__] [__]
right they don't know that people are
just trying to connect and then they get
Hella offended there's like hella times
when like people are like oh I love
oriental people and then they're just
trying to like connect and then people
are like how dare you say Oriental this
is so [__] wrong and I'm like the
[__] is wrong with you this old granny
is just trying to connect yes exactly
and you got to put her on game you got
to show her that like yeah you probably
shouldn't say that but you know yeah
that's why I don't think we should get
mad at that older generation cuz they're
they're trying to figure it out if we're
barely figuring out what binary
non-binary is like imagine them they're
lost that's our [__] they're like what
the [__] that's our [__] that's our [__]
that we are we should be more like you
should know better you should we this
generation should know better but that
older generation just let them be they
don't get it they're never my dad can
barely say hello [__] so let him figure
you know how the [__] is he going to
figure out [__] I'm binary he's like
I just learned how to say good
morning now I gotta find out yeah now
he's got
a I don't know I don't know and I don't
care it does suck that like people
forgot about intention you know like
some people's intention was never to be
racist but then they just get all the
flame from like no you're racist like
dude they were just being nice and said
something wrong but evales my feelings
when I call someone racist you know what
I mean I saw I saw a park a fight on the
parking lot feels good it feels good you
know what is crazy I saw a fight in the
parking lot and they were uh the first
thing they did when they were arguing oh
yeah yeah I'm about fing and I was like
that's our goto that cuz a phone out
makes you get a little tense like oh
[__] is going to go up you know but
that's the first move and I never KN
noticed how like a flashlight on a
phone you don't know if I'm recording
guess what I'm not you know what me but
I could just pull out my phone like you
[__] you know who the [__] you're
talking
to do you have a go I lie yeah dude I
lie know how many [__] followers I
have you're busted buddy you are busted
they're live streaming what's your go-to
if someone started recording you and was
my go pull my dick out dude my that
makes people nervous like that makes me
go hey hey hey wait wa don't do don't do
that don't do that like I'm [__] cuz
you can't post it I'm [__] you want
to [__] if it's a live stream it'll
get cut don't do exactly D I'll get them
[__] banded for a month sorry
couldn't go live this some big pulled
this dick
out so that's the Trump car dude
whenever I dude whenever I do a show and
people are just trying to be sneaky and
just [__] try to record I'm like hey
put that away I'm going pull my dick out
and they're just like oh no anything but
that
you're trying to jack your set yeah by
the way the by the way the most
confident people confidence and I blame
you guys you guys what the most
confident people that come to my shows
are JK news fans really confident they
love you dude I'm talking about in the
front [__] and they're like Jesus and
then I Tred to I onario I had a guy in
the [__] front just waiting wait I
contacted I'm just like what's going on
and I made fun of him she like yeah
drink our news and I'm like of course I
should [__] going he it yo keep
supporting guys just heckling by saying
JK news JK news comes out but then the
ones that laughs laugh the hardest super
supportive so yeah you guys your fans
are [__] confident hey your fans bro
your fans now yeah yeah yeah love them
dude I love them keep them coming dude
they're cool they're cool I always I
always say this but like I'm so glad
that we have cool fans like every time
you look around you're like they dress
good they're normal they don't sank I
know
that's a trifecta right there I know a
lot of YouTubers and I see their [__]
fans and they look horrible yes and I'm
just like God dang dude you know what it
is you cultivate like the shittiest
people on the world we get the best
people in the
world they're down to earth and one
thing I would say when I meet them it's
like I know them right away we're into
bits and right away we're already having
conversation it's not like we're already
in it we're making a bit before you know
they're adding to it I'm like oh sh we
know how to Ri so that's pretty cool how
they're just like down to earth imagine
backfires and they're just finishing all
your
jokes [__] they're all funnier than me
when are you going to do
the hey do the transgender joke do the
transgender J with your dad news it's
like all right [__] don't Heckle guys
you better [__] behave yourselves
they don't Heckle but they just have the
face like I wish you would say something
to me they're going to come with the
[__] Chinese Chinese to the front oh
dude that would listen I would [__]
die and I would love it at the same time
they came with those Chinese hat and
just like sit in the front chines Dan
hats I said did I
says no no that's a new one no but they
always come on y'all always come up
in our hands are cold man yeah yeah yeah
is that what it is if any of you guys
have the guts go get that outfit show up
to one of shows front row sit there the
funniest thing is half of our fans are
Asian so they're going to [__] roll
up looking cultural I swear to God that
[__] would make me laugh Iron Monkey
[__] and I would love it I would love if
you guys did that they're going to just
show up in normal clothing ha going to
be like you did it yeah
baby yeah dude so [__] silk robes
dude yeah I'm just uh there's certain
things that I'm uh I'm starting to like
be brave about to to try like uh you
know what's one thing I want to try that
yach uh is it Thailand that egg or
Filipino yeah yeah yeah you want to try
that I want to try it you know what it
tastes normal like at like a regular
okay what's normal cuz there a [__]
bird if you don't look at the bird
you're like I've tasted this [__] before
Oh beef oh I've had tastes like it just
tastes like chicken little McNugget
little MC do is it has a rough smell
it's like a wet McNugget when you go to
Wing Stop how do you eat your wings do
you eat it where it's just all bone is
gone or do you have like chunks of ctil
meat stuck on the ends it's [__]
clean and guess what and guess what cuz
you're used to the crunchy Crunchies I'm
going to say it right now uh I've been
eating bone okay an Asian friend taught
me how to eat bone crack and a half oh
you can suck on the marrow and then suck
on the marrow wow that that's already
that's already adjacent to ballute yeah
really a couple years ago I tried I
tried that's my thing it's like am I
eating the beak and the feathers or do
eat the whole thing it's like eating a
McNugget at PL wait so hold on when it's
in your mouth you can't tell are you
eating all of it you eat all of it not
the shell but the bone everything yeah
bone shell you suck the amniotic fluid
you're [__] with me you're [__]
with I swear to God serious no it's it's
soft you can't tell y bone beak feathers
all oil Chinese it just looks like [__]
you got to have you have chicken feet
first dip some and then we can level up
that's true chicken feet is a good place
to start chicken feet is a good place
cuz it's like similar right guys I say I
say we take some cameras and you guys
take me to the spot and I try some some
[__] let's do it I want toy some right
after that dog the you know what I I
think a had dog already I think a had
dog already in Mexico they [__] uh
some they do dog tacos in Mexico AP
courses some tacos no cuz we've been
having this Taco spot in Mexico and like
we've been going to and then my dad
[__] He's by the way I understand why
my dad's watching like the news Mex if
we're in America it's like don't even
watch news in Mexico about the mother
yeah he's still
like some guy died in the and I'm like
here he's like mexo look and I'm just
like yeah why you watching Mexico that's
unintentional dog right that's not like
Ulin hardcore I didn't show up for the
dog I didn't show up for the dog no do
you show up for like I came for the
[Music]
dog